what's up it's Shawn Mendes and I'm
doing a wired autocomplete interview
this should be interesting
we're asking does Shawn Mendes so we
have does Shawn Mendes have tattoos yeah
is one two three four he has five
tattoos this is my first tattoo it's a
guitar reflected on water with a sound
wave and a landscape of my city Toronto
I say my city it's actually a drag city
does shawn mendes have siblings I do I
have a younger sister who's 14 her
name's alaya she's way cooler than me
and way smarter than me the Shawn Mendes
like Camila caballo I love Camila Camila
she's one of my best friends of all time
does Shawn Mendes speak French I can say
escazu Palio toilette which means can I
use the bathroom which is the only
phrase I ever learned because I was just
trying to get at a French class all the
time does Shawn Mendes speak Spanish I
can say comemos which means we eat and I
can say gracias which means thank you so
no he doesn't is Shawn Mendes a tenor
technically I guess I'm a tenor I don't
believe in the fact that there's bass
tenor and stuff I think you can train
your voice to sing as high as you want
and maybe not as low as you want but I
definitely think you can train it to
sing really high is Shawn Mendes having
a tour in 2018 I'm not I'm gonna be
going on a big big festival run across
the world but then 2019 I'm gonna be
going on a real tour hey Shawn Mendes an
actor he tries to be an actor that's for
sure I think no I think I will be an
actor eventually I don't know if I count
as one yet though if Shawn Mendes
Hispanic I'm Portuguese that's where
that Hispanic look comes from Shawn
Mendes American he's extremely Canadian
he's proud of it
what is Shawn Mendes kicked I don't have
kick but if I did I wouldn't tell you
what bar Shawn Mendes fans called I
think they are referred to as the Mendes
army but I don't like to speak on behalf
of them I think you should ask them what
was Shawn Mendes the first song my first
song was life of the party I love that
song still what is it my blood about in
my blood is about overcoming fears of
anxiety what school does shawn mendes go
to I don't go to school I graduated high
school and now I'm free I'm not kidding
schools awesome I would maybe go to a
music school if I was if I was in
college right now I'd love to
study guitar and voice did Shawn Mendes
go to college he did not go to college
did Shawn Mendes win a Grammy he wishes
he won a Grammy the Shawn Mendes
finished high school I did finish high
school I finished because my teachers
are angels sent from above and they
helped me through it this Shawn Mendes
have braces I had braces for four and a
half years there's lots and lots and
lots of photo evidence I'm sure you can
pull up a few but Shawn Mendes start on
YouTube I did actually believe it or not
everybody says I started on vine the
truth is it was YouTube and then I
started posting vines I thought my
Google searches were much more
appropriate than I was expecting and I
loved it I want to do this again in like
three years and see what happens